Hi I'm Michael Morris I am the Deputy
Electoral Officer for the Invercargill City
Council and I'm going to give you a quick run
through about the by-election that's coming up.
So a by-election happens where
you've got a sitting Councillor
who resigns during the term of council within
the three years, meaning that there's a vacancy
created amongst the council table so
rather than 12 councillors we have 11.
We can't have 11 Councillors because the number
is set during our representation review process
of how many Councillors we have on each council
so for Invercargill City we have 12 plus the Mayor
which means that if we have a vacancy we have
to fill it. So anyone throughout New Zealand can
stand and become a candidate all you have to do is
be enrolled to vote somewhere within New Zealand
which given we've just had the general election
means most people should be and then you all you
have to do is be nominated by two people who
are residents of the Invercargill City district so
that includes Bluff in case people are wondering.
Voting begins on the 26th of January which is when
New Zealand Post starts delivering the postal
ballots. If you don't receive your postal ballot
you're free to come in and make a special vote so
just come into the Civic Administration Building
or the Bluff Service Centre. The election day is
the 17th of February and polling closes at 12 pm